the reaction from republicans to joe
biden's first speech before a joint
session of congress
was pathetic childish and ignorant which
are three adjectives that
they often i could be describing almost
anything the republican party has done
over the last few years as pathetic
childish and ignorant and it would be
accurate republican senator
tim scott gave the formal rebuttal and
we'll get to a couple of clips of that
but fox news gave the informal rebuttal
as i'm calling it and we're going to
look at clips of that as well
immediately after the speech
in an interview with fox's sean hannity
house minority leader kevin mccarthy
again brought up that joe biden wants to
control
how much red meat each american eats
this was never believable from the start
it's now been totally debunked
and a different fox news program
actually apologized for falsely
reporting that joe biden wanted to
control meat eating
mccarthy doesn't care he repeats it
again he just continues
he wants control of your life he's going
to control how much meat you can eat
can you imagine that then here is a fox
news host
sean hannity complaining about how joe
biden walked he didn't like
the the gates that's g-a-i-t of joe
biden walking into the speech
you watch the the i call it the biden
shuffle
it's like uh you know the little baby
steps that he takes as he walks and
little elbows looks like it's an effort
i it doesn't seem to be a vitality
in in in how he approaches this
very substantive as you can tell and
by the way it's weird to complain about
how joe biden walks when donald trump
had to be helped down the ramp at west
point by a military general but
what do i know it seems that people in
glass glass houses
shouldn't throw stones but apparently
sean hannity having nothing left but
that to do
senator ted cruz who again you know
earlier we saw dozing off
during joe biden's speech he summed the
speech
up this way well look i think the speech
tonight
you could sum up in three words boring
but radical and then much of the
reaction
was not about the proposals but about
masks and distancing check this out
by the way this needs to be said you
know all the people in that room
they've been fully vaccinated congress
they they were first in line
back in december uh we do we not have an
explanation
why can't that room be full why is
everyone still wearing masks
now of course we know the answers to
these questions they always they
they love you know when when your
audience is uninformed and doesn't know
any better
you can ask questions and pretend we
don't have answers
and get them on board by saying yeah
that why don't we have the answer to
that but we have the answers
the cdc guidelines are vaccinated people
do not have to wear masks in small
indoor gatherings
there is still enough of an unvaccinated
population
and 50 000 cases a day spreading that
at a large event people should wear
masks
regardless of vaccination status in part
because you don't know everybody's
vaccination status
the house chamber with 200 people in it
even if it's not the full 535 members of
congress plus staff that would normally
be there
it's not a small group vaccination was
not mandatory rand paul i think didn't
get his
i don't remember now but i think you
know you do not know the vaccination
status of everyone in the room it's not
a small group
that's why it's not super complicated
that's why they're wearing masks
plus so many of hannity's followers
are so dumb that if they saw a room full
of 535 people without masks
they would think it's okay for them and
their unvaccinated friends to start
doing whatever the hell they want so
the answer is actually quite simple as
to why this is the way it was done
the defenders of uh donald trump also
are suddenly very concerned about the
nuances of cdc guidelines here is
another from fox news they were never
concerned about trump's rallies or
anything
listen to the concern now well first i
want to talk about what i what i'm
seeing and you know martha you mentioned
these people who are all vaccinated
being indoors socially distancing with
their masks on
that's against cdc guidance it's not
just that that's theater it actually
shows that the united states is at a
weak point when the congress can't show
up
in full to show that the united states
is standing strong after coming out
of a pandemic that was caused by china i
mean if you give
a joint address to a congress that is
not even half full
does it really even count as a joint
address to congress i mean i think
that's
really a question the other thing that i
yes we look
weak because there weren't more people
at joe biden's speech give me a break
guys here's one more about this
basically the only thing that fox news
had to talk about
was masking and distancing i think it's
worth
noting at the top just the feel of this
room
and the fact that he talked a lot in the
beginning about covid about pulling
through
covid and getting through this era
that really marked so much of his
candidacy
and yet you have this new cdc guidance
that came out
just this week which said and i'll read
it to you
fully vaccinated people can visit other
fully vaccinated people indoors without
wearing
masks or social distancing so you just
have to ask yourself
if this is setting an example looking
forward for the country of what everyone
can expect the country to be like
in this period where people now i
have very open availability to vaccines
really asking the tough questions huh in
his formal response to joe biden
republican senator tim scott referred to
what
he says was the most inclusive economy
of his lifetime
under donald trump before covid
thanks to our bipartisan work last year
job openings are rebounding
so why do we feel so divided
anxious a nation with so much cause for
hope should not feel so
heavy laden a president who promised to
bring us
together should not be pushing agendas
that tear us apart the american family
deserves better
and we know what better looks like just
before covid
we have the most inclusive economy in my
lifetime
you know i really don't recall that
magical period
of bipartisanship and unity under trump
that tim scott
is referring to trump in fact
statistically
has been the most divisive president in
the modern polling era
but he wants us to believe it was ginger
snaps and candy waterfalls and rainbows
and all of this stuff
and overall i mean tim scott's response
was just very weak
it felt like it had no testicular
fortitude
behind it here's one more clip our
public schools should have reopened
months ago other countries did
private and religious schools did
science has shown
for months that schools are safe but too
often
powerful grown-ups set science aside
and kids like me were left behind
of course more and more schools are open
and things are opening and it's like
this is your criticism much of it
doesn't even have to do with joe biden a
lot of these school decisions or state
decisions
individual school decisions i know
school principles i know people on
boards of education and it's not joe
biden that's deciding
anyway so a completely vapid
flaccid substance-free reaction to joe
biden's speech
both in terms of the official response
by republican senator tim scott
and by fox news and the fact that they
have nothing substantive once again
is a sign that joe biden is generally
speaking on the right track
because the critiques aren't substantive
because joe biden is proposing things
that are widely speaking popular
necessary and well received by the
american people
let me know what you thought of the
speech you can find me on twitter at
dpakman
if you ever feel like you just don't
have enough time to read all the books
you want to read
you have to check out one of my favorite
apps called blinkist blinkist takes
thousands of popular nonfiction books
and distills each one down into an
e-book or
audiobook that you can get through in
just 15 minutes where you're getting all
the key takeaways from the book
just imagine how you'll be able to
expand your horizons and knowledge
by being able to soak up all of the
important
insights from 10 different books in an
afternoon obviously it's perfect for
exposing yourself to a new book
you otherwise wouldn't have time for or
you can use it to revisit a book you've
already read
or use it to preview a book before you
buy the full version and read it
i recently read a brief history of time
of course by the great
stephen hawking this is a book that i
have been aware of for so long and
other things got in the way and it was
fantastic
to check it out on blinkist blinkist has
books on politics philosophy science
they have 27 different non-fiction
categories and a subscription
is only about eight bucks a month and
you get the entire
library but you can try it totally free
and get 25 off a subscription when you
go to blinkist.com
pacman i've put the link right
underneath this video